So, are IQ tests valid? That is, do they measure intelligence, or do they
measure something else, such as a type of education you received, or how
wealthy your parents are? In fact, it's the question of validity that's
generated so much controversy regarding IQ tests. There are different types of
validity, but it all boils down to, does a test measure what it's supposed to
measure And also, does it predict the outcome it's supposed to predict?
>> Now, the key here is not to overstretch what you think an IQ test can tell you.
Now, an IQ test does have pretty good predictive validity in some areas such as
academic success. So, it's good at telling you how good you'll do in different
academic domains but not general life success.
>> That's right. So IQ tests are good at predicting school achievement. Or even
the type of college that one gets into. In fact, that's why Binet developed
intelligence testing back in the early 1900's. Interestingly, IQ tests can
predict the general type of career one goes into. Whether that's law
enforcement, accounting, or even construction. And it's also interesting to
note that IQ is related to longevity. With people with higher IQs living
longer.
>> Now, when people use an IQ test to try to tell you different important life
outcomes like, being emotionally stable, generally happy, or having a
successful marriage, you don't see a relationship between IQ and these domains.
So it's really important to limit what you think an IQ test is going to tell
you.